DR JAMES GRIME: We did a video.
I'd done it some time ago
about Mersenne primes.
And offhandedly, just
off the cuff, I said
that 1 wasn't a prime.
Now, if I'm honest, we
don't say 1 is prime.
There's a special
reason for that.
And we noticed that some people
in the comments said,
well, I think I've heard of this
before, but why is that?
Why isn't 1 a prime?
So what is a prime number?
Let's think of the definition.
You probably know
the definition.
A prime number is a number that
can only be divided by 1
and itself.
So the prime numbers are
2, 3, 5, 7, 11, 13.
You know these numbers.
So it sounds like 1 should
be a prime number, right?
It fits the definition
of the prime number.
You can divide by 1, and
you can divide by
itself, which is 1.
And historically, it was
considered a prime number.
So if you're thinking, hmm, it
sounds like it should be.
Well, that's what they
used to think.
That's what mathematicians
used to think as well.
But in the end, they
had to exclude it
from the prime numbers.
Oh poor old 1, 1 is the
loneliest number, the
loneliest number
you'll ever do.
So it's excluded for a reason.
There's a really important
theorem in mathematics.
It's called the Fundamental
Theorem of Arithmetic.
Now, it says that every positive
whole number can be
written as a product by
multiplying prime numbers.
So here it is.
I didn't want to write it
out, so here it is.
Every positive whole number, or
integer, if you like, can
be written as a unique
product of primes.
So you can tell this is an
important theorem because it
has a name.
And you can tell it's a very
important theorem because it
has a pompous name.
So what this means is prime
numbers are our atoms, like
atoms in chemistry.
They can be used to make other
numbers by multiplying these
primes together.
So for example, 15
is 3 times 5.
3 and 5 are prime.
And you can make 15 from
multiplying primes together.
But there's a very important
word here in this theorem.
Look at this word, unique.
Now that's not just there
for decoration.
Every word is important,
unique.
It has to be a unique product.
There's only one way to do it.
Now we know, of course, that
15 is also 5 times 3.
We don't mind that,
that's allowed.
We don't mind that.
What we don't like is that
15 is 1 times 3 times 5.
Not only that, but it's also
1 times 1 times 3 times 5.
And it's 1 times 1 times 1 times
3 times 5, and so on.
If 1 was a prime, then we
wouldn't have a unique way of
writing 15 as a product
of prime numbers.
So what this meant was, when
they used to think it was
prime, they had to keep
excluding 1 from your theorems.
You would have to keep saying,
take all the prime numbers,
except for 1.
And we just got tired
of doing that.
So we just decided to exclude 1
from our definition of prime
to begin with.
So 1 isn't a prime number.
It isn't considered a composite
number, where you
make the other numbers
from primes.
No, it has a category all of
its own, where it sits, all
lonely by itself.
BRADY HARAN: But why does
this mean 1's not prime?
Maybe it's just a
stupid theorem.
Maybe the theorem's no good.
Why does the theorem
beat number 1 out?
DR JAMES GRIME: We have a choice.
We have a choice to include
it in that category
if we wanted to.
Prime's just a word, it's
just a category.
And it's more useful for us to
say, take this list, which is
the list of all the primes.
And it doesn't have 1 on it.
It's more useful to say,
take this list.
And that list is 2, 3, 5,
7, 11, blah, blah, blah.
BRADY HARAN: Looking at that
theorem, doesn't that mean
that 1 isn't a whole number
because 1, surely 1 can't be
made as a unique product
of primes?
DR JAMES GRIME: OK.
Well, let's have a look.
Let's take--
I'll start with 16.
16 is a product of primes
because it's 2 times 2
times 2 times 2.
It's four primes.
8 is a product of primes.
It's 2 times 2 times 2.
So I've just divided
by 2 there.
4 is a product of two primes.
The number 2, the prime number
2, is a product of just one
prime number.
And then if I divide by 2 again,
I get 1, which is the
product of zero prime numbers.
It's called an empty product.
So we've got a product of 4
primes, 3 primes, 2 primes,
continue the pattern, 1
prime, and 0 primes.
It's 1, and it's not 0.
It's 1, it's called
an empty product.
Oh, that won't be it
for the number 1.
We'll be hearing from the number
1 again soon, I'm sure.